bueno
hola buenas noches a todas y todos hoy
vengo invitarlos a bailar tranquilos no
ya entre un ratito si esté la danza es
muy importante en nuestras vidas a mí me
la cambio y me ha hecho muy muy muy
feliz y todas las comunidades todas las
personas bailamos principalmente cuando
estamos felices cuando celebramos es
cierto es como siempre que hay un motivo
para festejar la danza así aparece y es
algo que le hace muy bien a toda una
sociedad muchas personas de la danza
estamos trabajando en eso un país que
baila es un país más feliz un colectivo
de personas instituciones públicas y
privadas colectivos de la danza estamos
trabajando para construir un plan
nacional de danza para que todas y todos
bailemos lo haremos mejor todavía si ese
plan se está construyendo y este año de
sueño crucial para nosotros porque vamos
a tratar de escribirlo para que después
sea con un nuevo gobierno podamos
empezar a practicarlo si es importante
que ese plan se ejecuta desde las voces
de todos y de todos y estamos en ese
momento de convocar
la danza llega a mi vida una forma
bastante extraordinaria yo ya estaba
cursando derecho bastante avanzado y me
encontraba haciendo juzgados en la
ciudad de montevideo cuando pasé por la
escuela nacional de danza de pasada vi
el cartel de las inscripciones entré me
inscribí a las pocas semanas vi la
prueba y quedé que he pasado de edad yo
tenía 22 años iba a comenzar los cursos
con 23 querer que tanto ahora estoy acá
hablando de danza hice mi vida
profesional estudié baile en compañía
viajé hasta que bueno el cuerpo cobra
factura y del escenario este maravilloso
y otros también maravillosos el
escenario de la danza se convirtió en el
salón de clase y ahí comencé en la
docencia
uruguay empezaba a transitar un nuevo
camino en la educación con una muy buena
reforma que incluso el arte en el
bachillerato de las opciones
tradicionales empezó a haber
bachillerato de arte y nuevas
asignaturas entramos a la currícula de
los liceos el problema es que no había
profesorado para esas materias
entonces artistas de la danza nos vimos
impulsados a ir al salón y enseñar y
compartir el problema estaba en que de
qué forma y vamos a dar danza no porque
todos venimos de las técnicas entonces
aprendemos a través de una persona que
está adelante un perdón que está delante
de nosotros y que se mueve y aprendemos
de esos pasos tenemos que buscar llegar
a ese estereotipo sí y en ese camino hay
mucha gente que fracasa ese modelo creo
que todas y todos lo conocemos y sobre
todo quiero ver ahora voy a ver sus
manos levantadas quien no sufrió en la
escuela tengan que bailar un baile
obligado se van de la mano
a esas cuantas personas y fue en
seguramente un momento bochornoso que
los marcó ahí nacemos los troncos los
descoordinados los que no podemos bailar
y quedamos ahí para toda la vida ese
modelo este empezamos a ver con un
colectivo de docentes que compartimos
que compartimos experiencias fuimos
generando la teoría desde la práctica y
llegamos a un modelo mucho más inclusivo
donde apuesta a que cada persona
voy a experimentar su corporalidad la
danza también en la escuela había tenido
una reforma que ayuda también un poco
por ese lado con más presencia del arte
sobre todo el teatro y la danza y esa
fuerza tendría que habilitar sigue a
cuerpos más diversos a todas las
personas en nuestros cuerpos y vaya que
si hay algo que tenemos y que es nuestro
en nuestro cuerpo el auto a la casa de
todo eso no sabemos pero nuestro cuerpo
es nuestro y acá dentro tenemos nuestros
problemas nuestros pensamientos tenemos
nuestras alegrías nuestras emociones
nuestras heridas de guerra los problemas
de salud pero también cargamos con mucha
discriminación en nuestros cuerpos desde
muy chica si es muy chicos entonces
cuando nos presentamos como docentes de
danza en una escuela por ejemplo tenemos
que garantizar que todos los cuerpos
puedan participar que la danza sea un
espacio alegre feliz de encontrarse
creando expresando comunicando siempre
en colectivo donde no sea concurso donde
haya no hace un estereotipo al llegar
para desde ahí lograr conectar con la
danza
la danza en la educación debe degenerar
no bailarinas y bailarines ojalá sería
genial creo que además todos y todas
somos bailarines y bailarines en
potencia sólo hay que poner play
entonces tenemos un desafío un desafío
de cómo comunicar
ese mensaje y hoy les voy a traer como
ejemplo para hablar un poquito de cómo
es la práctica cuando se como es la
clase de danza en esta modalidad no es
la búsqueda de un cuerpo libre
espontáneo que proponga que compartan sí
y les traigo un proyecto que desarrolló
hace ya siete años en el bachillerato de
arte en la región que es el estudio más
cercano oeste colonia san josé que es un
denso trabajo y en conjunto con otras
personas que dan esta materia
coordinamos un trabajo que es un aula
ampliada rompimos con el salón de clase
y entramos a un salón nuevo donde va a
haber trabajos virtuales dólares
trabajos de integración para crear
juntos y vamos a ver el producto de ese
trabajo del año pasado
[Música]
el día
y
qué es
actividad en los estudiantes permitirse
que ellos propongan que de ellas y de
ellos salgan las ideas permite su cuerpo
todavía más liberado
y esto es como una miradita no esto es
un producto final esto tiene muchas
etapas ya comenzamos planteando ideas
creativas en las cuales trabajamos en
esa belleza lo hacemos todos juntos en
un listado que sólo vamos a hacer ahora
este año por el día internacional de la
danza
luego practicamos en las aulas nos
volvemos a encontrar en el encuentro
regional que hay participan también los
tintos somos casi 300 personas en
socialistas
a estudiantes docentes obras que
disfrutan y allí presentamos en la
intimidad de la comunidad
la obra que estamos generando para en
tercera actividad es el montevideo se
llama un día para la danza tiene
festividad bueno tenemos la posibilidad
de reflexionar y hablar la danza fuimos
de un año la posibilidad de conversar
con maría ruiz esto que recién había
ganado el benois de la danse
tuvimos también la posibilidad de tomar
clase con alguna artista referente de la
danza a nivel nacional y ahí tuvimos el
placer de contar con carolina bisturíes
y el quehacer de contar con grassi las
fiero andriánova a hernández que
enriquece y une no la danza del lugar
este más artístico con este grupo de
jóvenes que están interesados en el arte
aún a 17 18 y realmente es muy motivante
y nos vamos como broche de oro a verla
hacer la función no vamos a bailar ahí
con el público
de nuestra obra en el valley nacional
del sobrevivió la función que tenemos la
necesidad
[Música]
y qué
sí
entonces trabajamos para poder despertar
esta movilidad con técnicas más
contemporáneas en la danza con técnicas
de danzas inclusivas como por ejemplo
danceability que es una danza que
trabaja con todo tipo de capacidad con
ejercicios y dinámicas que proponen la
expresión corporal para habilitar la
persona se sienta primero en confianza y
después libere no su cuerpo conocerse
compartir con el otro nos hace muy bien
además como sociedad y vamos eliminando
todas esas discriminaciones que
recibimos en nuestro cuerpo no
discriminaciones que recibimos por
nuestra altura por nuestro peso por
nuestro color de piel porque si soy un
hombre que me veo femenino si soy una
mujer que me veo masculina porque
empezamos a encontrarnos con nosotros y
con el otro entonces eso mejora nuestras
relaciones
la danza abre esas posibilidades sí
entonces bueno esa es la invitación para
bailar y era una invitación concreta
porque tampoco le vamos a dejar en estos
los invito a bailar y nos vamos no
entonces no sucede así desde el plan
estamos trabajando con una brillante
idea para celebrar este lunes ese día
internacional de la danza ya que tenemos
la invitación
[Música]
así que este lunes van a tener
actividades por todo el país así que
dónde se encuentren pueden acercarse ver
participar conocer qué pasa en la danza
en su territorio y también por qué no el
territorio del cuerpo poner un poquito
de movimiento y compartirlo con quienes
estén ahí en san jose amos a falcón
actividades aquí en la ciudad y también
en libertad y aquí no soy a pueden
acompañarnos el lunes entre 5 y 7 en
peatonal sarandí y asamblea va a ser una
experiencia realmente nueva en nuestra
comunidad así que lo estamos recibiendo
con muchísimas muchísimas ganas y
entusiasmo no pudo terminar esta charla
realmente pensando sólo en palabras
entonces yo tengo una danza como hay
público para muchas personas que amo que
adoro y que hoy forma parte también de
mi identidad que se cantó hombre por
supuesto no solo así que mientras que
amigos que me suben así que voy a
presentar a un saludo del órgano digo
núñez y el ángel garcía
pañero
compañero no quería explanada la
comparsa que con amigos y vecinos hace
diez años que estamos forjando cansan
josé para hacer visible el candombe
no voy a bailar solo si por supuesto que
me traje a una gran amiga compañera que
he aprendido mucho de ella mi amiga
tania ramírez activista por los derechos
humanos
evita
el cantón verdes contaba yo vengo de una
familia de mucho arraigo popular pero la
murga el canto popular este el candombe
un poco pero no es de tanta actividad no
somos nos vamos una familia a comparecer
ahora si no somos
pero empecé a vivir también
profesionalmente con la danza en anime a
salir en comparsas pero realmente hoy me
di cuenta y hace más tiempo que lo viví
en una forma muy carnavalera un
superficial porque estamos hablando de
una cultura que es una cultura profunda
una cultura que tiene una historia
cuando yo llegué al cine en donde miguel
fue mi directorio donde me encontré con
tania conocí ese contenido importante
que tiene cuando menor que es una
cultura afro las personas blancas han
construido han compartido por supuesto
pero es una cultura afro viene desde esa
historia y como tal tiene que hacerse
como una cultura de resistencia anti
racistas no nos alcanza con decir yo no
soy racista para luchar contra el
racismo y el candombe es una herramienta
y la comparsa es la herramienta social
que hace visible a sacándome y por eso
lo disfruto porque creo plenamente que
para poder convivir en una comunidad sin
violencia y más sanas del bosque bailar
tenemos que compartir si ya eso los voy
a invitar ahora al sol del candombe si
por favor
[Música]
[Aplausos]
nos ponemos de pie y vamos a compartir
de santaló